let's go next to
um where are we going
let's let's go to hold on where
we have so many people popping up let's
go to juan
from phoenix arizona juan what is going
on
hey what's up david how you doing i'm
good i love your show
bye no problem i i'm just curious about
your opinion on people like
john kasich and the lincoln party
grifters
all attacking progressives even though
progressives won
overwhelmingly and progressive policies
won overwhelmingly
on election day absolutely i actually
did a segment earlier this week which
is on the podcast already but we're
saving it for the weekend on youtube and
it's called
these republicans are not your friends
and
you know mitt romney big anti-trump
republican mitt romney
two days after the election he was on tv
saying hey listen my priority
is stopping medicare for all stopping
tax increases
stopping business regulation making sure
no one stops gas
and oil john kasich as you're pointing
out anti-trump republican defiant and
principled goes on tv says you know the
the joe biden better not let any
progressives influence his policy so
much like we predicted these are not our
friends we use them to the extent that
they're useful
for getting rid of trump we got rid of
trump they're going right back you know
the debt
the deficit all this stuff these are not
our friends full stop
yeah i mean i i agree 100 i just
i just think it's interesting and then
watching aoc try to fight back against
it i'm just worried that
the progressive party is going to take a
big hit if the entire establishment
decides that it's bad
but you're saying the progressive wing
of the democratic party
yeah yeah and but a majority of the
democratic party don't even like the
progressive wing
of it so i'm i'm worried about the
progressive
or the progressive wing of that party
yeah no that's you're you're
we talked about that on the wednesday
bonus show and we're going to keep
talking about that but this is this is
an important issue um listen i don't
want to hold you up it sounds like
you're writing a term paper so i'm going
to let you go okay
all right i appreciate it david yep a
lot of feverish
typing going on there we don't want to
there seems like important work is
happening and we don't want to get in
the way of that